thing in Turkey knowledge is in Boston
at Brigham and Women's Hospital
and assistant professor of medicine at
Harvard Medical School and my um I was
invited to give this discussion
regarding the clinical utility of Rena
and measurement and hypertension I have
a clinical and a research interest in
Rena and how it might be used to help
differentiate various types of cardio
metabolic conditions as I put up the
disclosure slide I'll just make one
disclaimer I'm in no ways an expert and
readin assays so I'm going to try to
focus most of my talk on clinical
applications of rain and so we'll get
started with a case because I think it's
a little bit easier to introduce the
topic there's a 54 year old male who
presents with a history of resistant
hypertension this was diagnosed of age
35 following an emergency room visit
after a motor vehicle accident both of
his parents were reported in of
hypertension in their 40s and he also
has an older sibling by age 41 with a
history of hypertension and I have a
graph down below that shows his body
mass index which has increased steadily
from age 27 2008 from 24 to 36 and when
asking about his medication history
reports being placed on
hydrochlorothiazide when he was first
diagnosed with hypertension and then
with this was added with metoprolol and
then an ala chrome and this is exchanged
from load of T Nasser he developed a
cough to enalapril his blood pressure on
visitation was 158 over 94 with a fugly
elevated heart rate they have note he
had an echocardiogram in 2009 which
revealed moderate concentric ventricular
hypertrophy is evidence of the
chronicity of his disease
other significant history consists of
him quitting tobacco use 15 years prior
history past heavy alcohol abuse but
none in the last two months no present
drug use although he admitted to
dabbling in the past he reported no
control of his dietary salt intake and
he said he was mostly a sedentary
instead of watch playing basketball
games he enjoyed watching his kids play
basketball games he was a machinist by
trade and had sporadic work lately his
past medical history aside from
hypertension consisted of a miss mixed
disability mia of about eight years for
which she had a cardiac stent for what
was reported as did dizziness and
interestingly he says despite having
this spent he still has dizziness he had
a rotator cuff repair and after scopic
knee surgery for a torn meniscus on exam
he's obese he has a notable 20 inch neck
circumference and he has evidence of end
organ damage in his eyes with
retinopathy
no audible breweries were encountered
his laboratory tests revealed a
marginally low potassium of 3.5 a normal
serum creatinine a slightly elevated
micro albumin and a plasma reading
activity which you'll note was somewhat
suppressed at their point not fixed
nanogram and 1/4 cc's per hour and an
elevated aldosterone level of 69 grams
per deciliter of note a 24-hour urine
collection was obtained which revealed
an elevated sodium of 216 millimoles and
an inappropriately elevated aldosterone
which we will talk about later
so the diagnosis here would be
consistent with primary
hyperaldosteronism he had evidence of a
suppressor Enon activity and elevated
aldosterone and an inappropriate
inappropriately elevated aldosterone
despite the high sodium intake he was
treated medically with 100 milligrams of
spironolactone daily this was
subsequently changed to a player known
due to development of gynecomastia and
his blood pressure was well controlled
as was his Jim potassium levels so I
think this typifies how lean in
measurements are used more and more
lately and it so the most part has to do
with the assessment of resistant
hypertension and the increased
recognition of primary
hyperaldosteronism in that population
so I'm going to quickly review some of
the background and lean in itself the
renown of the molecule was discovered in
1898 by Tigger said in Bregman and
Stockholm it's actually a pre-pro
molecule 406 amino acid with a mature
molecule Rina being 340 amino acids and
we see here i bipartition the slide into
two segments the upper segment is trying
to depict the the renal component of
Rina
which is the juxtaglomerular apparatus
where JG cells and you can see that
prolene in has a pro spent which is that
darker blue blob within the Rina
molecule this is proteolytically cleaved
to active Ranen meaning is actually an
enzyme with the responsibility of
converting angiotensinogen to
angiotensin 1 which in turn is converted
to angiotensin 2 which affects blood
pressure on the lower half of the slide
you'll see extra renal production of Pro
Rina which has been described in various
tissues including the adrenal gland
retina and ovary I point out that Pro
Rina in itself can have two
confirmations and this is important when
it
utilizing and interpreting various reen
in measuring assays the close
conformation is what pro-iranian is
mostly in it's 98% of the time in that
position and that is typically
undetected by reading and measuring
assays
however the open confirmation of program
and consists of about two percent and it
is indistinguishable from a state
measurement so Ashley assays that
measure the reen in active enzymatic
site will detect and report both reading
concentrations as well as pro rena
concentration in the open conformation
as far as the effects of rainin on the
cardiovascular system there are three
major stimuli for secretion of renin
they include hypotension probably most
profoundly followed by sympathetic
stimulation and then decreased sodium
delivery all these leads of secretion of
renin which I mentioned converts
angiotensinogen produced by the liver
into angiotensin one through an
enzymatic process
angiotensin one has been converted to
angiotensin 2 by converting enzyme in
activity and then angiotensin 2 produces
effects that ultimately raise blood
pressure through at least three
mechanisms through stimulation of
aldosterone production and sodium
retention volume expansion the direct
ways of constriction to increase blood
pressure and via antidiuretic hormone to
raise blood pressure and you can see
this knowledge of these enzymatic
processes and various steps throughout
the rain energy tension aldosterone
system had led to the development of
specific antagonists at each step beta
blockers interfere with mean and
secretion by blocking the sympathetic
stimulation drive reading inhibitors
block irenan activity so that it cannot
convert angiotensinogen to angiotensin
one ACE inhibitors block the conversion
of angiotensin 1 to angiotensin ii and
angiotensin ii antagonists type 1
antagonists block the effects the
terminal effects of angiotensin 2
finally aldosterone can be its actions
can be blocked by minerality corticoid
receptor activity antagonism
interestingly to compare different beta
different reading attention aldosterone
system blockades rena n-- in particular
leads to an elevation and leaning
concentration exceedingly a rhenium
blockade leads to an elevation
rina concentration but lowers plasma
renin activity whereas the other
antagonists will raise reen and
concentrations but also raise Lane and
activity the ultimate negative feedback
is via angiotensin ii and atonic process
so lean and measurement is essentially
measured by two methods the first would
be described as enzymatic activity of
the arena and enzyme and this is most
often described as plasma renin activity
typically this is a radio amino acid
that measures the amount of angiotensin
1 generated over a period of time it's a
somewhat cumbersome and expensive a
seeing is very technician heavy and it's
incredibly sensitive to poor sample
handling temperatures will affect the
folding and unfolding of the prolene and
molecule which can affect the detection
of the enzymatic the active site so
there must be particular proper handling
samples to maintain a reproducible
result reproducibility is good but it
has poor sensitivity of very little
values and that will come into play in a
minute on the next few slides
typically the normal values are 1 to 4
in nanogram frames of and eaten someone
converted four cc's per hour and this is
typically done in a seated upright
position in the morning for best
reproducibility interpretation a second
way of measuring rainin is by direct
measurement of rina concentration this
is typically done by an automated Meo
metric assay it's comparatively easy
although it does have some limitations
and that rina concentration itself
measures the concentration of an enzyme
but does not reflect its
maduk activity and its substrate
dependent meaning that estrogens
and other molecules that alter the
substrate concentration in this case and
each and Finnigan can affect the total
amount of lean and measured yet not
reflect the amount of reading activity
produce normal values are typically
eight times that measured a plasma renin
activity measuring eight to thirty five
million 'its per liter and that's a
pretty good rule of thumb of trying to
convert between flattening and activity
measurements and Riaan concentration is
about a one to eight ratio it's
important to remember the various
factors environmental and otherwise that
affect reen in a measurement and
particularly on the left hand is upright
body position the reading age intensive
systems exquisitely sensitive to the
effects of gravity so maintaining
upright posture or at least maintaining
a rigor and standard operating
procedures for measuring rainin will
enhance reproducibility and the ability
to interpretate properly the aging
process generally leads to a decrease
and measured greenin both reading
activity in reading concentrations
african-american race also tends to have
lower reading concentrations and there
is diurnal variation of rain and with
higher concentrations observed in the
morning hours pregnancy is known to
affect rainin by raising levels and the
luteal phase of the menstrual cycle has
variably been reported to raise rain in
by some investigators the second most
important factor to to remember are the
medications that are often in place
while somebody is measuring leaning
diuretics as one might imagine lead to
vine depletion and a reactive elevation
and reading activity as that is sense as
i previously mentioned beta antagonist
will suppress the
that the static nervous system drive on
rain and secretion by the kidney ACE
inhibitors and ARVs again effectively
negative feedback on plasma lean and
activity and rainin inhibitors in
particular can be difficult to interpret
depending on the assays as they can have
variable effects on both reading
activity and reading concentration
medications that tend to have less of an
effect on measurement of reading or the
activity of reading activity include
hydralazine and alpha antagonists and
sometimes these are chosen when trying
to interpret the effects of green in in
a case of hypertension by replacing
other medications that might alter lean
in activity
as I mentioned dietary salt intake is
probably one of the most important
factors environmental factors that
affect our ability to accurately measure
Rena and its impact on blood pressure as
reading as excuse me as sodium intake
dietary sodium intake increases reading
activity should be suppressed
unfortunately the problem is then the
u.s. dietary salt intake is fairly high
ranging between 7 to 9 grams of salt per
day or about 150 170 millimoles of
sodium per day in other countries such
as Japan this is even factored and you
can it is even higher so you can see how
this would be an increasingly important
factor and try to interpret the
sensitivity of a Rena in measurement as
the slope drops off and again that will
come into play as we discuss some of the
clinical applications for measuring
llenan so how exactly is rena used
clinically i would say in my opinion is
probably in the measurement or the
assessment of causes for resistant
hypertension and then beyond that it's
probably less used except by specialists
and that would be to measure assessments
of adrenal incident Aloma
measurements of potassium disturbances
assessment of renal reserve and how much
meaning can be produced by the
functioning kidney or failing kidney and
then very rarely it's used to measure a
situation such as adrenal insufficiency
or cushion or Cushing's as I mentioned
at the onset llenan activity measurement
is an incredibly active area of research
since rainin reflects a due volume state
of the circulating vascular system so it
can be invaluable in as a research tool
to assess volume status blood pressure
function and cardiovascular function
in general as I mentioned at the onset
probably the number one cause for the
uptick and Lina Nass a measurement is
the recognition of a higher prevalence
than previously recognized a primary
hyperaldosteronism as you can see from
this graph around the time that
hyperaldosteronism was described by Khan
and the late
mid 50s it was thought that the
prevalence of this condition was fairly
low but you can see over time has been
recognized either through a combination
of increased screening or enhanced assay
detection that in the general
hypertensive population we see a
reported prevalence of primary
hyperaldosteronism between five and
eight percent and when looking at
referral hypertensive referral
hypertension centers that prevalence
rises to 25 percent resistant
hypertension is probably as I mentioned
the number one reason why drainin would
be measured and according to the Joint
National Committee seven definition
resistant hypertension is described as
an above gold blood pressure of greater
than 140 over 90 this is generally
despite three optimal doses of anti
hypertensive agents key here is implied
adherence so medications must be
consumed I'm not just prescribed does
not necessarily mean maximum doses of
these medication but it must include a
diuretic or the presence of three anti
hypertensive agents controlled or not so
you can see how this definition can
include quite a large group of the
general hypertensive population the
prevalence has been difficult to know
it's been reported by in Haines and
Framingham that about 50% of
hypertensives
are are controlled and high-risk
populations such as those with diabetes
and chronic
kidney disease only about a quarter to a
third of preached are able to reach a
goal blood pressures however that
doesn't necessarily mean they're
resistant because compliance would have
to be assessed first our best guess has
probably come from all hat which
reported a 34% uncontrolled blood
pressure rate on to antihypertensive
medication or n Hanes which showed a 15%
rate one can estimate that since BMI
diabetes and age are all risk factors
for the development or conversion to
resistant hypertension that the
prevalence of the state will increase
over time it's important to investigate
secondary causes for resistant
hypertension obstructive sleep apnea has
a very high prevalence in causes of
secondary resistant hypertension but
I've outlined here three particular
conditions which have to do with Raymond
and this would be renal disease primary
aldosterone ISM and renal assessment of
renal artery stenosis other causes which
are much rarer include pheochromocytoma
Cushing's through a multifactorial
series of events a hyperparathyroidism
and a hora court ation the biochemical
evaluation of primary hyperaldosteronism
hypertension usually begins with a basic
chemistry panel and a urinalysis we
typically in our Center also measure
morning rainin and aldosterone if it's
highly suspicious
then we'll obtain a 24-hour urine
creatinine sodium potassium plus or
minus the addition of aldosterone met an
afferent and free cortisol and the
reason why we tend to do that at onset
is one where referral center into the
there appears to be a
a higher prevalence of high sodium
excretion in the population I would say
less so these days of the is the
investigation for renal artery stenosis
only with very high suspicion such as a
younger women acute onset or in older
individuals with no natural sclerosis
would there be an investigation for
renal artery stenosis the interpretation
of the aldosterone lean in measurements
is important and I've divided I'll
divided into three states the first
would be described will describe as low
renin States and these would be as you
might imagine conditions that would
suppress reen in activity either due to
hyperactivity of another volume
dependent hormone or through volume
overload state in general as I mentioned
the probably the most prevalent would be
primary hyperaldosteronism in which the
measured aldosterone levels very high
but the reading activity is low and
suppressed similar to this would be
ingestion of licorice this would have a
has high in mineral accord quit activity
it would suppress aldosterone but it
would also lead to volume expansion in
suppression and arene and secretion much
rarer would be doke secreting tumors 11
beta hydroxyl ease deficiencies and
ectopic ACTH
the next category would be a value
returned in the new meaning in the
normal range sometimes this can be
observed and Kisch conditions of a
Cushing syndrome in which both normal
aldosterone and normal activity are
observed this would be followed up with
investigation of cortisol measurement if
clinical suspicion was high finally the
last category would be a return value of
rena in the high range again this would
be probably most consistent with reno
vascular disease in which there is
impaired blood flow to the kidney and a
perceived hypotensive event which leads
to a stimulation of Ranen so both
reading activity was high and
consequently aldosterone activity would
be high as driven by Renan much rare
would be rena Noma or a tumor which
secretes rainin
but importantly malignant hypertension
so in the evaluation of a patient and
emergency room who presents with
hypertensive urgency or emergency is not
uncommon to measure very high levels of
irenan aldosterone and meta nephron
activity as one can imagine if there's a
relative bond deplete state circulating
volume deplete states such as congestive
heart failure and nephrotic syndrome is
cirrhosis one would expect to see
elevated reading and aldosterone
activity
in measuring and screening for primary
hyperaldosteronism probably the number
one cause secondary cause for resistant
hypertension the aldosterone llenan
ratio is most often used it is at one
could imagine heavily dependent on
Brennen which resides as a denominator
unfortunately there have been no
established cutoff values for plasma for
this aldo renamed ratio for plasma renin
activity has generally been between 25
and 50 for use of reading concentration
in the aldo raine and ratio the assayed
sensitivity as reported by several
societies including American Heart
Association requires a sensitivity to
less than one point two nano grams per
liter or a lesson to no international
units per liter for use of plasma renin
activity in the elderly Ninh ratio the
assay sensitivity should be able to
measure less than 0.3 nanograms per
milliliter per hour and these again as I
mentioned become important because of
the suppressed wean and values we
naturally see in a high sodium diet so
where there's an increased dependency
and weight to lean and residing in the
denominator of this aldo raine and ratio
the ability to measure rena accurately
at very very low levels is important for
plasma renin activity this usually
becomes a stumbling block and often at
assays will depend on a prolonged
incubation period of up to 18 hours in
order to accurately report meaning
activity when concentrations are less
than 0.5 milligrams
from milliliter per hour optimizing the
sensitivity includes morning sampling a
standard operating procedure for being
seated from 5 to 10 minutes typically an
unrestricted salt diets and at least 2
hours out of bed in the morning other
disease states beyond primary
hyperaldosteronism that might alter
rainin include primary adrenal
insufficiency the phenotype is often
that of hypotension and hyperkalemia and
as one could imagine in a volume
discrete state the rainin activity would
be very very high secondary adrenal
insufficiency truthfully has hypotension
and normal queuing and we typically
don't see a markedly elevated rainin in
the state as the hypotension is not as
profound and there is not hyperkalemia
chronic renal insufficiency is a state
of hypertension in hyperkalemia
depending on the degree of renal
insufficiency this may impair reen and
secretion or rena production so reading
levels may be low in the situation as
mentioned leading secreting tumors lead
to profound hypertension with
hypokalemia and reading levels would be
markedly elevated any syndrome or
genetic defect of steroid biosynthesis
can lead to either symptoms of hypo or
hypertension and potassium disturbances
and as one could imagine the effect on
Rena secretion is variable depending on
the degree of hyper or hypo tension
so in summary rainin is the
rate-limiting step that we see in the
production of angiotensin ii formation
it is a cute regulator of blood pressure
and volume homeostasis
Nina measurement is increasingly
important in the evaluation of
hypertension a valuable excuse me at
available ab c--'s reflect either reen
inactivity or active leaning
concentrations and the interpretation of
rena values is dependent on the
collection condition and it saw an
understanding of the environmental
influences that affect leaning so at
this point i'll entertain any questions
that you might have and certainly feel
free to contact me at my email listed on
the screen or if you need a copy the
slides that i'd be happy to provide that
as a PDF file so i'm going to look over
at our questions screen to see if
there's any at this time and if there's
any participants they can ask questions
at this time
so I have one question here that asked
can a single rainin measurement we use
to determine treatment for a newly
diagnosed hypertensive patient that
would depend on the suspicion for
resistant hypertension state so at the
time of diagnosis of hypertension if the
blood pressure is markedly elevated or
there signs of symptoms that are
worrisome for a secondary cause such as
chest pain early age severe onset or a
striking family history then lien it
could be measured at the onset I would
say that would be a rare condition and
that weaning is most often measured in
evaluation and resistant hypertension
resistant hypertension typically
develops over time or is described over
time and not at initial presentation
let's say most hypertensive patients who
are resistant hypertension it is
discovered after a series of trial and
error medication maneuvers so there
might be a initial medication to
attempted to lower blood pressure
without a optimized effect and then a
third medication is added so a few at
least two or three office visits would
occur with assessment of blood pressure
response to standard medication and then
after failure of that those medications
to optimally
control blood pressure despite compliant
or evidence of compliance then a
biochemical evaluation for resistant
hypertension including measurement of
reiden would would typically occur
so at this point we given the low
prevalence of primary hyperaldosteronism
and the general hypertension population
and in particular in stage 1
hypertension we are not screening with
rena for that condition one can imagine
that as well one can imagine a primary
hyperaldosteronism in some regard must
start at some point and even individuals
who enter into a diagnosis of a
hypertensive with a marginally elevated
blood pressure even if vipera even if
inappropriate aldosterone secretion is
the mechanism behind that it may not be
realized until several months later as
the adoptionism grows or worsen one
would hope that as our abilities to
better phenotype and characterize the
hypertensive population either through
genetics or other methods that we be
able to detect these individuals earlier
and one can envision a day in which we
would be able to determine who exactly
has a particular tendency to develop
resistant hypertension or even primary
hyperaldosteronism with some sort of
screening tool either lean and
measurement aldosterone measurement or a
combination with genetics to better to
better treat these individuals so next
the next question that we have is are
there any suggestions on educating
physicians on switching from a PRA
result to a directly NAND result
I thought assuming this is referring to
the conversion of the actual number so
as I mentioned earlier typically plasma
llenan activity values are reported
between 1 & 4 whereas renal plasma
meaning concentrations are between about
8 and 35 so a general rule of thumb I
use is to
apply the PRA by 8:00 or divide the TRC
by 8:00 - to interpret the values or
interchange them I'm not sure if that's
answering the question
and I'll wait to see if there are
additional questions at this time
so once so a great question that was
brought up is what tests are used to
confirm a diagnosis primary
hyperaldosteronism
usually there are three tests the ones
that we use in our Center is an oral
sodium loading protocol
so once the screening aldosterone renal
ratio is confirmed we typically do a
salt loading this consists of about an
additional hundred to 150 millimoles of
salt and take orally per day now you
have to be careful with that depending
on the degree of hypertension so if
somebody has profound hypertension we
probably wouldn't do that we haven't
come into our inpatient center for an
evaluation in addition to salt loading
it's important to realize that that that
can exacerbate potassium losses so
typically will prescribe potassium oral
potassium replacement during our salt
routing protocol so we'll salt load for
three days and on the third day we'll
ask our patients to begin a 24-hour
urine collection they then bring that
urine collection to our lab at the end
of the third day or the beginning of the
fourth day actually and what we measure
our urine creatinine total volume
potassium aldosterone and sodium and by
most by both by most measures the
definition autonomous aldosterone
secretion would require a urinary sodium
excretion above 200 millimoles for
24-hour period and in measured
aldosterone excretion rate in the urine
of above 12 to 14 micrograms per 24-hour
period my typical normal value would be
less than 8 so you can see there's a
gray zone in defining hyperaldosteronism
I'm just going
there's a couple of other questions here
which is the preferred method for
reading Maginot that's that's a tricky
question to answer I think one it
depends on the confidence of the the lab
used so certainly both plasma reading
activity measurement and plasma arena
concentration are used widely and the
ability for some of the measure plasma
mean and activity precisely depends on
the the conditions of the collection so
if there's a high degree of confidence
and that the collection is being done
correctly then more often than not most
of the guidelines follow plasma renin
activity now that might change as more
sophisticated reading concentration
ashley's occur and are validated
relative to their performance to
platinum reading activity
I'm just gonna flip through a couple
more questions here
so here's an interesting question is
there any evidence that explains that
suggests why african-americans have
lower reading levels independent of salt
intake and that that's certainly a
question that we ask in our research
group it's it's I guess it's easy to
speculate that it's a combination of
genetic pressure and environmental
conditions so it's certainly clear that
when we compare African Americans in our
research cohorts with our Caucasians
that they have universally have lower
plasma renin activity and then when we
look at their genetic makeup of you
terrine in polymorphisms angiotensin ii
polymorphisms in gh and centage and
polymorphisms we definitely see a
discrepancy and the prevalence of those
pi morphic variants so so there's
certainly a body of evidence that would
suggest that it has to do with genetics
or genetic pressure over time that's
leading to suppression of rena aside
from that there are certainly reports
that it has to do with dietary intake
such as dietary intake and potassium
sodium that might vary between
populations clearly an active area of
research that's not quite settled out
yet
so another question I have it that was
submitted is how do you handle the
collection challenges of samples for
your assays is it an endocrinologist
concern or or the clinical lab on the
CERN that exactly that clinical chemical
pathos so I guess it's a combination way
for our research purposes where we
needed to have very precise measurements
it actually ended up being an
educational endeavor where we would
describe the required steps to have an
accurate and reproducible lean in
measurement
I would imagine most large laboratory
setup that there is a standard operating
procedure for both the collection
processing and assay rina certainly as
with with most laboratory measurements
it never hurts to get two or three
assessments of reading activity to feel
confident with the measurement another
question is in resistant hypertension
associated with primary
hyperaldosteronism what proportion are
normal Colima can that that's a great
question because it's um I think in the
past and it probably contributes to the
changing rate and the prevalence of
primary hyperaldosteronism or the
appreciation of Emory is that we
classically had defined or investigated
primary hyperaldosteronism do not have
hypokalemia
where they have normal Kaylee McDowell
serum potassium levels so again if
there's a I think it's important to
remember that if somebody's requiring
more than three medications in spite of
normal Kaylee Mia to entertain
hyperaldosteronism
given its higher prevalence sometimes
that can be teased out as I mentioned
the use of diuretics is actually part of
the definition for Prime resistant
hypertension and often what we'll see is
an exaggerated a hyperkalemic response
to starting a diuretic such as
hydrochlorothiazide or potassium wasting
diuretic so sometimes I I find that
useful in unmasking primary
hyperaldosteronism obviously somebody
with lot large doses of potassium
repletion can have a normal clinic value
on evaluation but it would be up to the
clinician to appreciate that that no
anemic values and the setting of the
hide catching empty yeah this is another
great ones great group that another
great question I sure I have a solid
answer for this but it says how long
with patients have to be treated with
hydralazine until the leanin goes back
to it based on concentration that's an
excellent question so in the evaluation
of primary hyperaldosteronism clearly if
that occurs most often in a resistant
hypertensive state there would be
several medications on board each one of
those could interfere with the
interpretation of the reigning agent in
that system be an angiotensin
aldosterone system typically if it's
safer and probably just as sensitive to
lead patients on their matic
antihypertensive medications probably
with the exception of the mineral accord
acquit receptor antagonists
spironolactone and a player known which
would clearly alter the rialto rena
ratio but in most cases given the high
cutoff points for plasma arena
correction sorry for aldo rena and
ratios it can pretty much lead people on
their medications and the off chance
that you actually have to are it's not
clear we typically allow about a month
for
medications to wash out now if it's an
ACE inhibitor and ARB or even a mineral
a quartic co-receptor we've seen rhenium
activity maintained by the effects of
those medications out fit three months
in fact most of our research protocols
require that aces ARVs are washed out
for at least three months prior to
assessment or in that that may not
pertain to clinical relevance since the
suspicions somewhat different than in a
research standpoint but about a month is
what we typically redo in practice for
mineral accord code receptor antagonists
we've certainly seen up to four or five
months of persistent activity on the
median age extensive system after
washout
what is the treatment or care for
resistant hypertension that wasn't quite
where I wanted to go into talk but I
think it's a it's certainly a relevant
question it would be first identifying
those contributing causes so obviously
if there is established primary
hyperaldosteronism there would be either
removal of an elgato secreting tumor if
encountered or diagnosed or treatment
medically with men around corticoid
resistant okay excuse me mineral accord
receptor antagonist now i would point
out that there are several reports of
the potency of using mineralocorticoid
receptor antagonist in the treatment of
resistant hypertension there's been
reports of a large blood pressure
lowering effects in that setting that
might have to do with the ability of
aldosterone antagonist to provide a more
potent either diuretic effect or tamping
down of iranian angiotensin system and
in otherwise very heightened state by
reading angiotensin system activity so
often that'll be the drug that we pick
even in the absence primary
hyperaldosteronism beyond that we
typically turn to clonidine with a beta
blocker which is typically on board and
then I actually prefer minoxidil because
I think it's very potent
antihypertensive agent but must be
monitored carefully
a question asked is it vital to include
24-hour urine studies as their way to
screen for hyperaldosteronism or is ARR
enough so there's a two-part question
and then what additional information is
gathered from the urine study so the
alder Enon ratio is an excellent
screening tool but it's not a very good
diagnostic tool for aldosterone excess
it gives a high suspicion and certainly
I would imagine the specificity of that
test increases drastically as a ratio
arises but it is really meant to be a
sensitive test so to establish the
diagnosis of inappropriate aldosterone
secretion one must first suppress or
very or introduce measures which will
suppress normal aldosterone activity as
I mentioned that can be as simple as
loading with oral salt to a high level
or it can be a saline infusion or it can
be one of two less commonly use
antagonist procedures so the point would
be to raise a lot correction if you
would be to raise sodium levels to a
level that we know should suppress
aldosterone activity typically that's
measured in a 24-hour urine collection
so we can gauge the amount of sodium
intake relatively amount of aldosterone
that's encountered in the urine specimen
so that would typically be the
diagnostic assay for measuring
confirming the diagnosis of primary
hyperaldosteronism
so a question is how fast would you like
it rainin test to be is that a few
minutes
how many readings has the order mummy
help so I'm not sure if that's referring
to the plasma mean activity or the
reading concentration assay usually a
standard plasma reading activity
assessment is for 90 minutes but as I
mentioned it's even the incubation
period would be for 90 minutes but as I
mentioned sometimes depending on very
low concentrations detected that can be
extended out to 18 hours cost of
variable plasma reading activity costs
tend to be very high because they're
very labor intensive relative to plasma
reading concentrations which can be
measured with immuno metric assays
so somebody it asks how we might be able
to get a copy of slide so I think on my
last slide here posted you can certainly
just email me I'm happy to email out the
power practice Rea PDF file of the slide
set and then I just want to point out on
the last slide I'll put it up here there
is a wink for obtaining CME credit for
this activity which you can click on
there's a question that state asks is
there a benefit in classifying
non-resistant hypertension as as high
renown or low renin on certainly that's
my question I have two most of my
research has to do with determining
subsets within hypertension and the
endpoint would be clearly to perhaps to
provide more targeted and beneficial
therapy to the patient to improve
compliance decree cost etcetera so I
would clearly be biased in saying yes I
think there's a clear benefit for being
able to the subset hypertensives into
high rate and/or low rina that's
certainly been attempted in the past
with variable effectiveness as far as
targeting treatment one might think that
a lil Rena State would be one in which a
diuretic would be beneficial since the
loneliness state often reflects a Lyme
expanded state and therefore use of a
diuretic would be should be important in
that state
that's very been reported as successful
versus a high rated state one might
think you would block in the empty tomb
angiotensin ii or blocked any arena
activity very approximately it just
hasn't quite been worked out yet and i
think it probably has to do mostly with
the experiment experimental conditions
in trying to assess reen inactivity
they're not consistently reported by
investigators
so it's certainly an effort that's been
going on for decades to try to accurate
we classify subsets within the
hypertensive population in an effort to
improve
come
just flipping through a couple more of
these so since this was asked a few
times which method and measurement would
would you favor me myself act plasma
mean activity or any OS a and why I
guess we've been favoring the plasma
Mirena activity just because we're very
familiar with it and since we have most
of our research protocols our
longitudinal that's be very difficult
for us to switch over to a different
assay since it would interfere with our
kind of longitudinal comparison of our
population so that's that's probably the
most important reason why and then I
think the second might be that for right
now most of the societies that provide
guidelines in the workup of resistant
hypertension have been favoring plasma
mean and activity again maybe because
there's been more experience with that
and it's a little bit more standardized
but I would imagine as there's more
interest in measurement of directory
NAND and totally and that that will
change over time and excessive since the
cost should be much less of where
measurement of direct rainin than plasma
renin activity just yet to be seen that
the accuracy can be matched
so an important question is how do you
interpret the Rena and aldosterone
ratios and the setting of somebody who
is on an ACE inhibitor or ARB use
especially when patients have absolute
indications for these medications such
as condition the congestive heart
failure so that's a great question I
might have hit this one before but I
would say more often than not we will
continue to assess the aldo reading
ratio without withdrawing these
medications I think where you get where
it can be a little bit more difficult is
in the three months after initiation of
these medications
so typically aldosterone escape occurs
beyond three months so in the first
three months you can have you can have
difficulty interpreting the aldosterone
part of the Adaline and ratio so usually
we would wait and I can't think of many
cases where I've been faced with that
dilemma of entertaining a primary
hyperaldosteronism hitter but I would
think waiting three months would be fine
in order to provide a little bit better
reliability the ARR interpretation in
those patients
so there's been a couple of questions
asking which particular kits are we
using it I probably can't probably
shouldn't say that this for conflicts of
interest
this yeah this I'm not sure of there's a
question that asks is there is there any
data published for aldo raine and ratios
at screening for primary
hyperaldosteronism for mass assays
instead of activity acids there's this
by mass I assume that means plasma
meaning concentration there's certainly
been several head-to-head comparisons of
acids that been reported with very
variable degrees of confidence and
comparing those I'd say most of them
report that pleasant reading
concentration is as good as plasma
reading activity
I think what's difficult to interpret
are translating the clinical practice
are the conditions of a research study
versus those of clinical practice so in
a research study where you're doing
direct comparisons it's much more easier
to define your your comparison
populations to make sure they're as
close as possible so for instance
somebody who is on it was on oral
contraceptive or estrogen hormone
replacement they might be excluded from
a research study that's comparing
directory and concentration to plasma
renin activity however in clinical
practice that wouldn't be that may not
be possible so as with any research
study report you have to be able to
interpret the context of that research
and how flickable is going to be to your
clinical practice certainly there's been
a lot more activity and comparing the
two assays to report confidence of
Platon reading concentration versus
plasma reading activity and as I
mentioned at the onset I think where we
might see a lot of excitement is and
better defining the lower range of the
sensitivity of these assays given a
high-salt diet that we encounter it
becomes increasingly increasingly
difficult to measure plasma reactive
when there are high salt conditions and
I think there's more lien for poor
reporting false positives higher Avelina
ratios in that setting one would hope
that the measurement direct reading
concentration might have an advantage on
those lower ranges since they might be
able to have an amino acid that can be
more sensitive at the lower limits of
detection relative to plasma reading
activity so I guess I'm hopeful that
that can occur to help clean up some of
the noise we have in the tre assay in
particular when measuring or in trying
to excrete for primary
hyperaldosteronism a question is in your
opinion what's the true prevalence of
primary hyperaldosteronism and can we
speak of a cult primer how
hyperaldosteronism so I I we reported on
this in our group about I think was
about eight years ago because at that
time there have been such a high rate of
reported primary hyperaldosteronism and
we we ourselves were a little bit taken
aback by the reported rates and then
realizing that they're probably mostly
from referral hypertension clinics we
looked at our general hypertensive
population which actually excludes
resistant hypertension we were I think
of we reported a rate of about 6 percent
in a general hypertensive population
I think what's difficult to know is the
trajectory of the time course primer
hyperaldosteronism as with anything
somebody must start even those with
primer hyperaldosteronism must start
with a level of hypertension even a low
level of hypertension they don't they
don't wake up one day with a blood
pressure of 190 over 120 it's more
likely that they progress through the
spectrum of hypertension yet they do so
more quickly or more resistant lee of an
essential quote/unquote hypertension so
i think a cult primary
hyperaldosteronism certainly exists and
as I was mentioning earlier we just need
to develop the tools of detection so we
can identify those folks quicker and not
so late in the game when they have 10
years of accumulated damage and our
interventions are less effective so
there certainly needs to be a drive and
there has been there's been certainly
reports of genetic polymorphic variants
that lead to primer familial primary
hyperaldosteronism so there's hope that
that can be interpreted and translated
into screening individuals down the road
we're just not there yet so I think we
have about a minute left see if I can
pick one more of these what is the
clinical definition of resistant -
second I think I had that the clinical
definition would be AB uncontrolled
blood pressure greater than 140 over 90
that is despite use of three anti
hypertensive medications one of which
includes a diuretic and compliance with
those medications so there was a study
recently conducted where she which is
trying to enroll patients specifically
with resistant hypertension and given
the prevalence reported one would have
thought that would have been an easy
task however when placing the caveat of
eligibility that one must assure
compliance with medications before
defining resistant hypertension the
actual ability to recruit and identify
risen hypertension dropped down to 1% so
became increasingly difficult
so clearly compliance with medication is
a big part of diagnosing appropriately
resistant hypertension
and that should be that should be an
important part of evaluating it so I
think we're all set unless I hear
otherwise from the team
dawn you just let me know if there's
anything else again I'll refer to the
last slide which provides a length force
C II my credit and I'm going to flip
back one slide and push that to the
audience which again lifts my contact
information feel free to contact me at
my email and I'd be happy to try to
answer your questions and certainly
provide a copy of the slide set of the
PDF to you Donna let you sign out when
when you think we're done thanks again
you
you